Okay.
[Silence]
The stuff of nightmares.
It's nice having so many people for fud,
right? We usually have this amount, a
little less. You know what's interesting
about this? We could do it every day,
you know.
Yeah. I mean, that option is always
there. Mashallah. Lots of sisters here,
you know. I'm just saying the masjid is
open the same way year round and you
know just food for thought.
Continuing in
the book of fasting
and we are in the subchapter regarding
those things which are permissible for a
person who is fasting. Often times these
things are somewhat confused. Sometimes
people
are a little bit overly cautious when
they're fasting. They are afraid to
engage in normal activities that they
would otherwise engage in for fear that
it would somehow compromise their
fasting. When I was in the Caribbean,
there was
some custom down there going on and and
there's a lot of Muslims down there.
It's not a little bit. And Islam
has been there a lot longer than it has
here in America. it's somewhere
around 12 to 15% Muslims, right? So
huge. But you know, Trinidad is a is an
island. Tobago is an island and a lot
of people they work as fishermen, a lot
of people work as divers, a lot of
people work as
and one of the ideas that was
you know, interestingly enough, very
widespread
was that it was impermissible for a
person fasting
to submerge himself or herself in water
past their navl.
Anything beyond this, you broke your
fast. So you go into water that is to
your chest, your fast is broken. And
they believe this to the point that when
I told them,
this doesn't affect your fast at all. As
a matter of fact, you can continue to
dive to swim. And I even went with them
to swim. I had to prove it. go into the
water. Right.
They were shocked. Shocked that this is
okay. It's okay to dunk your head in
water. Yes. Dunk your head, you know,
swim completely, etc. , and so a lot
of times things begin as a custom or
what we call or refer to in America as
an old wife's tale, right? And they
catch on to where they almost become
fact.
And this is for this reason this
chapter and these kinds of chapters
exist and they are very important
because our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
went out of his way to
show the companions what was
permissible and what was impermissible.
what would break your fast and what
would not. So one of the things that is
permissible for a person who is fasting
is not only bathing but bathing for thee
with the intention of cooling off or
trying to relieve some of the thirst
that a person may feel.
Bathing
not just to clean yourself, not just for
but bathing for the purpose of of
cooling off.
[Silence]
forch.
Salatb
Abbas
anisam
to whom?
And so
Abu Bakr Abdman he's one of the he
narrates that one of the prophet's
companions
says
[Silence]
Medina. So this companion narrates that
he witnessed the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam in an area called
Arj. This is a small village a few days
out a few days travel from Medina
that he had gotten very hot or he had
gotten very thirsty while he was fasting
and he was witnessed taking water bucket
of water and pouring it on his head from
thirst or from heat
sai.
So this narration
is the evidence that the faukah used
that it is permissible for a person to
cool off by a way of bathing.
And it gets even more it gets deeper.
The next point that the author mentions
Foreign
[Silence]
for.
So the next is that a person
rinse his mouth
and his nose without taking the water
too far back into his mouth or in to his
nose to the point that it would get to
his throat. Right? Exactly as we would
do in wudoo. This would be for the
purpose of wudoo or this would be for
the purpose of cleanliness or this would
be for any other reason. It is
permissible for a person to rinse out
his mouth, put water in his mouth, put
water in his nose without exaggerating
that to the point that it would reach
into a person's throat or into a
person's nose. Sometimes there are
some statements that some of the have
made it's not permissible to take
anything into the mouth that goes beyond
the letter where comes from. However,
there's really no evidence for this. And
what the prophet sallallahiuh wasallam
said is not to exaggerate. That's all he
said.
And so a person is not to exaggerate in
taking this water into his mouth or
nose but it is permissible and this also
is an evidence that the mouth has the
ruling of being outside of the body.
Likewise, the in inside of the nose has
the ruling of being outside of the body.
And this is going to come into play in a
moment, inshallah.
[Silence]
And
the messenger of Allah S.A.I. was
teaching him how to
was teaching him how to make woo. And
one of his instructions was, "And take
the water deep, snort the water deeply
into your nose unless you are fasting."
So what do we understand from unless you
are fasting? Meaning if you're fasting,
do not snort the water deeply. snort it
into your nose but not deeply to where
it goes into the sinuses and then
empties back into the throat. Likewise
with respect to
now if we are to understand
that
the mouth and nose have the ruling of
being outside of the body.
Then this is an interesting point
because what if a person were to spit
something up
into his mouth
and then swallow it back? Would that
break his fast? Well, here we have a
couple of a couple of scenarios.
One, it is something that's coming from
the from the nose. You know how a person
clears his his I don't know what's
this area called back here but clears
this out and would usually swallow it or
spit it out. Would this be something
that breaks a person's fast? Likewise,
if a person is spitting something up
from here, fleg that comes up, you
would usually spit it out. But if they
were to swallow it back, will these two
things break a person's fast? And the
correct opinion of the fukah is that
neither of these two will break a
person's fast.
But then this brings back the question
which is didn't we just say that the
mouth and nose have the ruling of being
outside the body? We will say the mouth
and nose follow the source.
Meaning if something comes originates
from inside then the mouth and nose have
the ruling of being
part of the inside. And if something
originates from the outside the mouth
and nose have the ruling of being that
which is outside. And this is what is
referred to by the scholars as
and this has its rulings throughout the
Quran and Sunnah. For instance, it's
connected, right? Where it comes from is
where it gets its ruling. So, for
instance,
it is impermissible
for a person for a man to look at a
woman that he's not married to or is
not related to, right, with
desire. Okay, this is a person is to
lower his gaze. Correct. Well, what
about to just look at her dress or what
about just to look at her shoes? That's
not part of her body, right? Or or we
could reverse the genders. This is not
the point. We would say no. Anything
that is connected to her has the same
ruling. Right? But now let's reverse it.
What if that same dress was on a rack at
a store? Or if that hair were to be cut
and disconnected,
then a person could look at that. Why?
Because it is disconnected.
So these things they don't exist on
their own.
We can have another example. For
instance, it's not permissible to buy
something.
It's not permissible to buy something
that you don't know what you're buying.
Right? This is called and this is
impermissible in Islam. If I say to you,
for instance, I have a closed box. I say
buy this surprise box for $10. Right?
You could have something that's worth 25
cents in it. could have something that's
worth $25 in it. This is an
impermissible sale. It's not permissible
until you can clearly see what the
merchandise is.
But how about if I were to purchase an
animal that is pregnant?
Well, now it takes the ruling of the
animal that you're purchasing. Correct?
Because it is mutas. It is connected.
This is where the scholars get these
rulings.
So back to how we
put these principles into action,
we have
something that is flem. It comes from
inside the body, right? Whether it comes
from the throat or it comes from the
nose.
This is inside of the body. If it makes
its way into the mouth and then the
person swallows it back, this will not
break a person's fast. Why? Because now
the mouth takes the ruling of what? Of
the inside of the body. However, if
something were to come from outside and
make its way into the mouth and a person
were to swallow it, this would break
your fast. Why? Because it takes the
ruling of what? the outside
because I'll give you a good example
now. What about if a person stuck his
tongue out?
Think about it.
You have saliva on your on your tongue,
right? If you stick your tongue out and
then pull your tongue back in and then
swallow that saliva, do you break your
fast? Yes, you break your fast, Jimmy.
Yeah. So, it is impermissible to stick
your tongue out when you're fasting.
Should we surmise this?
Do you understand? So what what does
this mean? This means that
that saliva that is on your tongue, it
takes the ruling of what? What is
already inside of the body? Even though
it comes out of the mouth. However, if
you were to put that same saliva onto
your finger and then put it back into
your mouth, that would break your fast,
wouldn't it? Yes, it would. Which is why
the scholars mention the least of
breaking a person's fast,
right?
One of the
one of the
Okay. The next thing is al
another thing that will not break a
person's fast and we'll we'll end with
this one inshallah. The next thing that
will not break a person's fast is al hij
is cupping. Cupping. Cupping that takes
place Islamic cupping.
Okay. When we say hij
cupping is only when a person
uses a blade. This is called cupping.
[Silence]
And so cupping has to be with
cutting. There has to it has to involve
pulling out blood. We and why am I
saying this? Because in the west now
popularly in the last few years this
thing has cut on cut this thing has
caught on where it's a kind of
light cupping where they will take the
the actual cup and they will apply it to
places where you would usually
have the cupping done and they will
apply the suction but then they won't
cut it after that. They'll just make it
suck and then they'll take it off and
leave it that. That's not hij
that's not considered hij
involving what? Cutting. You have to cut
and pull that blood out. This is called
hijama.
And when was given to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam?
Huh?
Come on guys. What' you say?
Very good. A lot of you were here when
we talked about this that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam came
back with two things.
One was
the five salawat and two was hijam.
Now is a prophetic medicine
is a prophetic medicine is actually a
profound medicine
and
is it something that will break a
person's fast?
Well, Iban Abbas narrates in Sah Bkari
and this is one of the
three narrations
that are debated amongst the scholars
of hadith only three. This is one of
them.
[Silence]
The scholars have differed on this
narration but it is authentic as it is
and that is that Iban AB best narrates
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
did al while he was fasting. He did al
while he was fasting
and
there is another narration
that is abregated mans
in which the prophet sallall.aii
said
that the one who does the cupping and
the one who receives the cupping both
break their fast.
This is an authentic narration but the
narration is abregated. This was earlier
and later that was abregated by the
narration we just heard. person may say
we understand why a person fasting might
have their fast compromised by cupping
but why is it the one who performs the
cupping is his
fast broken imagine this you come to me
let's say Adam here he comes he says I
want you to do hijama for me I say I got
you don't worry so I do hij for him
based on this narration
My fast is broken and his fast is
broken. Well, we understand his fast is
broken because something's being drawn
from his body. There's something
physical going on there. But why is my
fast broken?
And the answer is that the way that they
used to do cupping in the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam's time is
that the one doing the cupping would
actually
use his mouth to suck the blood a
siphon. We know how siphons work, right?
Once you get the liquid,
come on, man. Our our masid didn't win
the science fair, right? A siphon. So
once you get the liquid a path
started for liquid other liquid will
follow because liquid follows the path
of least resistance. Whatever the point
is is that usually they would get this
started by using their mouth
to start that sucking process. And in
the process, most of the time doing it
that way, you will get blood into the
back of your throat. And so for this
reason, the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said that both the person doing and
receiving the cupping have broken their
fast. But if a person does the cupping
by way of fire, then it will not break
as fast. Or by way of suction, now we
have fancy gadgets that do it. This will
not break a person's fast but now even
receiving cupping will not break your
fast. We're going to pick this up again
tomorrow inshallah
because it's a very important
point and a lot of other things are
going to be based on this but we will
end there again tonight we will be
completing the Quran inshallah and we
have you know a very nice event lined
up. Please come out and be here and
you know be with us for this
celebration.
[Silence]
It's getting really fast.
[Arabic recitation]